-Fred, you are about to be
a guest on the show as well.
-Yes.
-And I just hope
you've thought through
how you're going to
play yourself on
while also moving
from there to here.
-I think I have an idea.
-Okay, great.
Our first guests tonight are two
very funny comedians and actors
you know from their work
on "Saturday Night Live."
They're producing and starring
in the new show "Forever,"
which begins streaming
on Amazon Prime Video,
Friday, September 14th.
Let's take a look.
-Wow.
-How gorgeous is this?
This is so beautiful.
-I know.
-Such a good idea, honey.
-Thank you.
Jesus mother[bleep] Christ,
that's cold!
[ Laughter ]
Good Lord. Jesus.
Is it gonna be that cold
everywhere?
-Is it that bad?
You're scaring me.
-Please welcome back to the
show, two of my favorite people,
Maya Rudolph and Fred Armisen,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Well done.
-Hi.
-You thought it through.
-We did.
-You really thought it through.
I am very impressed.
-Thank you.
-These are for you.
-These are for me? Thank you.
Guys, this is so exciting.
You're doing a TV show together.
Obviously you met on "SNL."
But you had seen Fred perform
before that?
-I did. I saw him at a club
in Los Angeles called Largo.
I think I had just started "SNL"
and I saw him --
He didn't see me.
Like, we didn't talk.
But he had bleach blond hair
and he was in a piece he wrote
with Mary Lynn Rajskub,
where they were
these Hawaiian --
What were you?
Conspiracy theorists?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And your name was
Leonard Wampanui.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
And we'd play audio tapes
of politicians --
George Bush at the time --
and we'd be like, "Think."
-Think.
-"Use your head."
-Use your head.
[ Laughter ]
And he -- immediately I was
like, "That guy's a beast."
[ Laughter ]
That guy is so amazing.
And then I didn't see him again
until I came to the auditions.
And he was dressed as Fericito
for his audition.
-One of the -- an early
character he did on the show.
Another early thing you guys did
together were the Nunis.
-Yes.
-For those of you who don't
remember the Nunis,
you guys were sort of --
Where were you from?
-Good question.
-Yeah.
-We never knew.
-It felt like Holland.
-Were we German? Dutch?
-You were like -- you were
a design couple.
You had very unique designs.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's Rainn Wilson
sitting on a pile of toast.
-We always
had different chairs.
You're in a basketball hoop.
-That's me there, right?
-That's you, yes.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-By the way, if you had offered
me $1,000,
I would not have been able to
tell you if I --
that's how long ago --
-I don't remember any of this.
-Who came up with the idea of
the Nunis?
-See, I don't know.
-I think we all think
we all did,
because I knew this guy
in Holland named Hejen.
And I'd be like,
"Okay, hi, Hejen."
He's like, "That's not how you
pronounce it."
And I would say "Hejen."
And I'm like,
"I am saying it right.
I'm not a dummy."
So he would just be like,
"No, that's not --
you're not doing it right."
But then, you had a similar
story, and then James --
-Well, my friend -- yeah, and we
wrote it with James Anderson
'cause all great things
come from James Anderson.
-One of the most prolific
writers in "SNL" history.
-He's still alive.
-Still alive.
[ Laughter ]
-My friend Gretchen told me she
went like, you know,
a year abroad or whatever,
a summer abroad,
after graduation
with her friend Shoshana.
And her name is Gretchen.
And so they met
these Italian guys.
And she was like, "I'm Gretchen.
This is Shoshana."
And the guy was like,
"Gracie, Shoshine.
Come to the disco."
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause the way it would work --
for example,
when I was in the sketch, I'm
sure at one point I said Nuni.
-Yes.
-You were both named Nuni.
And that was your first name.
-But they were different names.
-Yeah.
-But if I would say,
"So it's Nuni?"
-Yes?
-And Nuni.
-No, no, no, no. Nuni.
-Nuni.
-Nuni. No, no. Nuni.
-No, she's Nuni, I'm Nuni.
[ Laughter ]
-You have to say it
with the front of your tongue.
[ Laughter ]
-Nuni.
-No, no. Nuni.
That is a child's name.
[ Laughter ]
-Also Prince, "The Prince Show."
-Yes.
-And this was one of the best.
-One of the best.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Maya is Beyoncé.
Fred is Prince.
And you guys --
There was a time
where Prince
was the musical guest.
-Yep.
-And you wrote a "Prince Show"
for Prince to be in.
-Yes.
-And you had --
so I guess on Thursday,
you lined up to try to
talk to Prince
and settle on the idea
of the show.
-Yes.
-Yeah, and so we were poised
to speak to him
after his sound check,
so we went down there.
-And Prince's people had told
you, "Talk to him after that"?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-We've got the script.
We showed it to him.
He's gonna play,
and then he's gonna
talk to you guys after this.
Okay, great.
So the stage is right there,
and we're standing right there
for Prince's sound check.
Like, what could be better?
And she's like,
"As soon as he's done,
he's gonna come over
and talk to you guys."
He finished, takes off
his little, like, stuff.
Jumped off the stage,
walked directly towards us,
made a 90-degree right turn past
us, walked out the double doors
and into the elevator
and left the building.
[ Laughter ]
-Very Prince.
-We never talked about it.
-So I want to come back
after this commercial break
and talk about your new show.
But we are -- this is a sketch
that has a lot more
historical significance
than we maybe thought
at the time.
Paris Hilton was hosting.
-Yeah.
-Thank God.
[ Laughter ]
Not a show people
talk about a ton,
but there we are
the three of us.
Don Jr., Ivanka, Eric Trump.
[ Laughter ]
-What a picture.
-That is so --
That is so upsetting.
-That is a weird thing
that happened.
-Was that the week
that you started the bet?
-I did have a bet, yeah.
-The bet, was --
Can we talk about the bet?
-We might have to --
We might edit it out,
but let's tell the story.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So, so, no one could really
get Paris Hilton, our host,
to engage in
any personal conversations.
We realized, she hasn't asked
any of us a personal question.
And this one said,
"The first person she asks
a personal question,
I'll give --" a hundred bucks?
-Yeah.
-Didn't ask one person.
-No.
No, right?
-The whole week.
I thought she did.
-No, she got close and she asked
Jodie, "Is Maya Italian?"
[ Laughter ]